[Music]
the shot that makes all the difference
indian celebrities like filmmaker kamal
hassan getting inoculated for all to see
to encourage a country of over a billion
people to follow his example
[Music]
if only there were enough jabs available
for everyone instead
the country that's making vaccines for
the rest of the world is faced with a
massive shortage
how could this happen india's
vaccination rollout to all adults is
hampered by a creaking infrastructure
and a new aggressive variant that
spreads faster than anywhere else
if india fails what does this mean for
the global pandemic fight
welcome to our kobe 19 special good to
have you with us especially
if you're joining us from india i hope
that you and your families are well
and safe because the figures we get from
india are absolutely shocking almost 390
000 new cases of infection and more than
three and a half thousand
deaths within the last 24 hours
international help is getting underway
with the first emergency aid supplies
arriving from the us
but in the end it's all about getting
millions of shots
in arms s asap
prime minister narendra modi seen here
getting his vaccination
generally likes to promote india as the
world's pharmacy
but now the chief of the world's biggest
vaccine producer in pune
has slammed the indian government
because they didn't order enough jobs in
the last few months
suddenly the government is left standing
empty-handed
we don't have enough vaccines right now
we let you know as soon as we receive
the vaccines
compared to other countries india trails
the us with just over 42 percent of the
population
having received at least one vaccination
in india
157 million people have been vaccinated
at least once
that's a lot of people but just nine
percent of the population
the most popular vaccine in india is
astrazeneca
under the name kova shield after
three weeks kova shield offers 76
efficacy
after the second jab at 12 weeks this
rises to nearly 83 percent
kova shield is manufactured in india
with a license from the european
pharmaceutical company astrazeneca
until recently half of the production
went from here to destinations all over
the world
but because of the steep rise in the
number of cases at home
the indian government has stopped
exporting
this also applies to the second vaccine
produced in india
covaxin it currently can also only be
used in india
covaxin has to be administered in two
doses
six weeks after the first vaccination it
offers protection of 78
percent a third indian vaccine is
awaiting approval
psychovid should come onto the market
from mid-may
but will this be enough to vaccinate
against the pandemic
in india that's a big question
rajiv dasgupta is chairperson at the
center of
social media and community health at
jawaharlal nehru university in new delhi
joins us now
so good to have you vaccination
obviously seen as the only way out of
the pandemic
is it also the only way out of the
crisis in india
now the current crisis is really of
providing clinical
care of providing intensive care to very
large numbers
of being able to maintain infrastructure
and supply chains
that really is the current crisis also a
very large
requirement of human resources that
really is
is what's the burning problem now
vaccination of course is crucial but
vaccination is not going to address this
problem
in the short run which is a few weeks
that we are talking of now
but surely you're trying to still get as
many shots in arms as possible
how does this actually work in terms of
distribution do hospitals
order vaccines themselves or who is who
is deciding who gets the vaccine
well the indian government's
prioritization strategy had been by risk
categories
which meant health workers and other
first care responders first which is
which was scheduled over the first three
months and then
age group 60 and then age group 45 and
above that's what the prioritization
strategy was and from may 1st which is
tomorrow
it will be open for all adults above the
age of 18 years
but several states are facing a shortage
in vaccine supplies
and therefore realistically it's not
going to begin for the
18 plus group from tomorrow they will
certainly have to wait
till the supply situation stabilizes
how is it possible that there is this
shortage given that
india is actually providing the rest of
the world with vaccines
what's understood at this point is that
this rapid expansion to
45-year age group which was earlier
50-year plus with co-morbidities
this meant an additional demand of 200
to 250 million doses
which was not so readily available
and add to the fact that now that it's
18 years plus
it's a lot more doses of vaccines that
we are talking off
so this putney vaccine from russia has
been
approved got the emergency authorization
the first batches are expected perhaps
in a few days in the first week
of may as a direct import from
russia before being being manufactured
in india by one of the indian companies
so even if the sputnik arrives
on this schedule it's still going to be
several weeks before actual demands can
be met and therefore
several states have certainly postponed
this 18 plus
age group till till a few weeks down the
line
and given the fact that there are
already two indigenous
let's call them vaccines co-vaccine we
heard in the report
already approved and then there's
another one uh psycho d
which is due to get emergency approval
in may will those vaccines be for
indians only in order to hopefully as
soon as possible turn things around
the current emphasis certainly is to be
able to immunize as much as possible
again going by these by this
prioritization
principle as we understand
it will take still a few weeks for
adequate vaccines to be back into
the supply system to be able to at least
clear the
depending uh doses particularly up to
age 45
so all of these are certainly going to
add to the kitty but the next few weeks
things are going to be slow
and i don't want to i don't want to even
imagine what this delay means for
the situation that you're already in at
the moment
nevertheless this may sound heartless
but
what is this crisis in india what does
it mean for worldwide vaccine supply
will there be a knock-on effect for
example
when it comes to the kovacs program
yes it's very likely at least by
current projections the contributions
from india are certainly going to be
delayed
if not actually less so i'm sure the
kovacs
group would be worried about it
i think i think what what sort of got
misconstrued initially was that
india produces 60 of the global vaccines
which is true
in the aggregate of childhood vaccines
but in this category influence of
vaccines and so on
this contribution is actually to the
tune of 20
that experts say so that 60 figure is is
not entirely applicable here
just very briefly what lessons can the
rest of the world learn from what's
happening in india right now
i mean we're talking about a pandemic we
have to overcome it together
sure we have to overcome it coming
together we have to learn from each
other
uh i think the the issue of variance
of the of the mutant forms is very
crucial uh england responded to it in a
certain way the uk
strain which as we know then spread to
nearly 100 countries worldwide
became a dominant strain at at several
in several countries
similarly the indian strain the b1617
is also considered to be playing a very
crucial role right
uh and i think we certainly need to
learn from each other particularly how
variants are to be managed
okay rajib descriptor there from uh
the java harold nero university in new
delhi thank you so much and to stay safe
thank you thank you you too
time to answer more of your questions
now over to derek
how can genetic engineering be helpful
in fighting upcoming pandemics
genetic engineering is one of those
phrases that get thrown around a lot but
i found a
a surprising number of people don't
actually know what it means
so so let's define it before moving
forward when you
genetically engineer something you use
tools from fields that are usually now
grouped under the label
biotechnology to manipulate
and modify an organism's genome
the goal is to make it do things the
organism
wouldn't do otherwise for example
produce
a highly specific medicinal product or
produce it
in faster ways or produce it in larger
amounts
genetic engineering methods are now
common in areas
from from crop science to waste
mitigation
to sustainable fuel development but when
it comes to modern medicine
genetically modified microorganisms play
a really
central role nowadays for instance
microbes have been engineered to churn
out
much of the insulin that people with
diabetes
need to survive and and gene editing
methods are also key
to designing new medications they're
used not only
to manufacture a complex biologics like
like monoclonal antibodies but but also
vaccines
viral vector vaccines like those made by
astrazeneca
are like like poster child examples of
products made
with genetic engineering they work
because the designers were able to
splice
genes from stars cov2 into a harmless
adenovirus that that when injected
can help make you immune to covet 19. so
genetic engineering is much more than
helpful
in the fight against pandemics it'll
continue to be a crucial
facet of reacting to them
and containing them in the future
[Music]
and before we go biotech pfizer have
asked european regulators to authorize
their kovid19 vaccine for 12 to 15 year
olds and they also plan to seek
authorization with other regulatory
authorities worldwide thanks for
watching